CONVENES THE RULES COMMITTEE OF
FRIDAY APRIL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
TWENTY PLEASE ADVISE ON AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE THERE'S
ALSO BEEN TELEVISED OF MATTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE. ALL. OKAY COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM CORREO FLORA GRAYSON
RENDON. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RIVAS THERE
WHERE X. LEVINE WE A QUORUM
CALL WE HAVE A QUORUM I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE TODAY WILL
TAKE A CONSENT CALENDAR IS A
SORT OF THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
ALL OF OUR STAFF HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD VETTING ALL
OF THESE BILLS UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES I'M FOR IN PERSON
DID NOT JOIN US IN THE ROOM.
BUT ALL THE WORK HAS BEEN DONE
BY OUR STAFF AND I JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THEM ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE AND- I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT TODAY. REFERRALS WILL
NOT BE REGARDED AS FULLY
PRESIDENTIAL. IN AS MUCH AS
DOUBLE REFERRALS WERE SET ASIDE
TO EXPEDITE THE BUSINESS OF THE
HOUSE UNDER THESE ACCIDENTS
CIRCUMSTANCES. OF WAR AND BILLS
ARE BEING HANDLED BY COMMITTEE
STAFF COORDINATION SO- WE HAVE
JUST SINGLE REFERRALS TODAY AND
THAT'S KIND OF AN ADJUSTMENT OF
OUR PROCESS. BUT WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA AND AB THROUGH
THIRTY THREE SIXTY TWO BY THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
ADDED CONSENT BEFORE LIST. IS
OUR MOST ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SEC OVER MISTER. GONNA BERMAN
HEATH AMOUNT OF SIR PLEASED THE
ROLL. ONLY I COOLEY I CAN
CARILLO FLORA FLORA I AGREE SIR.
GRACE AYE RENDON RENDON I MAIN
SHOW MATHIS HI MY I WORK SO
FROM THREE. RIVAS I LEVINE HI
LEVINE I. THE MEASURE PASSED
AND THAT CAN TO WAS THE RULES
WITH YOU VERY DON'T. BECAUSE
YOU.